regardez moi ce truc de ouf que vous
avez le jolly et là vous avez le nymex 3
voilà pour quoi faire et quoi
[Musique]
aujourd'hui je vous montrais un produit
qui est hyper hyper cool ça change parce
qu'on peut vraiment sur des smartphones
a des très grands écrans et aujourd'hui
on va carrément affaires inverse
il n'y a depuis quelques temps et j'ai
pas encore pris le temps de tester lui
aujourd'hui on va tester le unis hertz
le jolly alors je sais pas si ce
smartphone vous parle pour mais
franchement vous allez voir c'est un
truc de ouf parce que on parle toujours
de smartphones avec des très grands
écrans aujourd'hui tout l'un vers ce
qu'on va faire
l'irak la boîte je vous mets un
smartphone à côté je vous laisse
imaginer la taille de la bête
est-ce que ça c'est pas tout mini tout
mini tout mignon alors commença sous x
10 6 pour toi alors est-ce que vous êtes
prêts la vache
alors ça ça c'est un smartphone 4g
regardez moi ce truc de ouf que là vous
avez le jolly et là vous avez le mini
max 3 voilà
faites votre choix vous préférez quoi
les grands écrans ou alors les tout
petits écrans le format est complètement
ouf regarder dans un an
comment ai je le pose à plat hop je peux
le faire mais on ne voit presque pas
c'est vraiment complètement hallucinant
et même la boîte c'est une micro en
boîte alors qu'est ce qu'on a à
l'intérieur de cette micro boîte une dup
qui vous explique comment ça marche
comment le brancher un pc alors à ce qui
est cool en plus intérieure c'est que
vous avez un double lecteur carte sim
c'est complètement hallucinant
vous pouvez en plus rajouter une carte
microsd pour ajouter du stockage vous
branchez ici au micro usb on vous avait
même une prise jack
ici je suppose les boutons de volume
bouton pour l'allumer pour l'éteindre
ici vous avez
les haut parleurs le micro qui est
directement sur le côté là ça c'est du
smartphone vraiment pour ceux qui
veulent pas s'embêter au niveau de la
taille ceux qui sont fiche de la taille
vous êtes tranquille avec un smartphone
4g et on a ici ici bloc de charge à
laquelle ça au moins on est tranquille
voilà protection d'écran qu'on enlève
pour l'installer il faut l'ouvrir là
vous avez les emplacements pour vos deux
cartes sim denanot sim ici une carte
microsd pour les rajouter du stockage et
vous avez ici votre batterie il faut en
le truc à l'ancienne incroyable ces
officines j'ai mon tiroir d'applications
ici le tactile fonctionne super bien
c'est hallucinant alors on a un androïde
7.0 à l'intérieur on a un nouveau gap
pains oreo ici google youtube qu'est ce
qu'on va voir sur youtube là-dessus
expérience de visionnage d'une de mes
vidéos sur un écran de 2,45 pouces avec
une définition de 240 par 432 pixels je
crois que là quand même
on va battre des records a jamais oui il
ya du souffle est complètement
hallucinante regarder youtube avec un
smartphone ophone femme assez
hallucinant alors attends romain
haut-parleurs qui est derrière qui se
situe juste lost s'est complètement où
ça marche ce jelly existe en deux
versions soit la version normale soit la
version pro la version normale c'est un
giga de ram 8 go de stockage et la
version de gros 2 gigas de ram 16 go de
stockage pour les deux-roues ici pas de
14 d'empreintes digitales moi ce que je
vous conseille c'est tout simplement
éventuellement mettre un petit schéma ou
un code ça fonctionnera très bien faut
pas vous embêter tout est pas optimisée
du tout pour cette taille d'écran
alors là je vais essayer
jouer ni 3 waltz aspac nitro plutôt d'y
arriver
ah ouais on peut quand même réussir à
jouer alors bon mois la vache c'est pas
mal
c'est quand même ouf parce que on peut
quand même joué que c'est petit écran on
y retrouve bien alors ça dépend des jeux
vous oubliez pour les forces niles
oublier les pdg ou d'oublier tout ça
vous ne prenez des petits jeux de
bagnoles comme ça qui ne prennent pas
trop trop de stockage achoppé lundi frau
au rouge
oh là là j'ai complètement exploser ma
bagnole tous les gens un peu gourmand là
dessus vous oublié parce que de toute
façon ça va pas tourner ça vous avez
quand même un rejet à version pro avec
deux gigas de ram de son quatrième de
stockage on va pas trop trop lui en
demander
malgré tout pour avoir un petit jeu
franchement ça marche le côté smartphone
est complètement au foot pour téléphoner
une pression c'est juste un clip mali
ces trucs mais au final ça marche super
bien puisqu'on est dans le côté
multimédia on va regarder ce qui se
passe du côté de la photo de la vidéo
alors là vous avez quoi
mode beauté faciale mode panorama mode
normal ou quai j'ai aussi le hdr que je
peut activer désactiver à la je passe
sur la caméra
ici j'ai mes paramètres gps géo
localisation l'exposition modes scènes
balance des blancs pour porter l'image
et il ya quand même pas mal de choses
pour voir comment un tout petit tout
petit smartphone c'est quand même assez
dingue alors maintenant on va tester
directement que lorsque ces dix caméras
de celle fille 2 mégapixels là haut
j'aurais pu me dire quelle coiffure
était pas terrible
l'enfant un petit peu un voyage dans le
temps quand même un pour passer sur une
de mes gars pixels mais bon faut
miniaturisés sur cette rue clark merad
derrière je pouvais faire un petit tour
du studio
voilà y est ça tourne bien le malt aussi
aller d'elle qui sont là aulas et de ce
que je veux en tout cas à l'écran alors
l'écran un tout petit j'ai vraiment mais
deux que je joue à l'écran ça marche
quand même pas trop mal à passer le
bonjour à donald qui vous fait une bise
l'abri sympathiquement maintenant on va
les tester la partie photo en temps
quelques clichés
en plus c'est un point qui est hyper
cool là dessus c'est qu'on a une prise
casque
donc on va l'essayer puisqu'elle est là
pour la phase gâcher le plaisir c'est
toujours le premier à râler quand il n'y
a pas de prise casque sur des
smartphones et à notre m'a fatigué
minuscule on a une prise casque
mais c'est moi le format il fait
complètement lucide
la bâche c'est hallucinant c'est
complètement hallucinant à la limite je
trouve que la qualité c'est franchement
c'est hallucinant
ça ça va ça et c'est n'importe quoi moi
c'est la version propre j'ai deux gigas
de ram 16 go de stockage
il coûte 135 euros je vous ai lien lien
d'un description les jeter un coup
d'oeil c'est franchement jeu sinon alors
ce smartphone il destiné qui a ce qu'on
est petit doigt si vous avez des mains
du front du genre au canadien voyez avec
la chemise à carreaux qu'il n'y allait
pas parce que quand même il faut il faut
être assez précis au niveau des doigts
ça se fait ça c'est intuitif mais il
faut être assez précis
après ça ce qui est génial c'est le
format pocket c'est à dire qu'avec un
produit comme celui-là seront recherchés
la mettre dans la poche très facilement
or pour tout mettre dans la poche à
pouvait mettre sa mère déclare garder ça
prend juste ça dans toute ma poche et
donc là franchement vous avez de quoi
faire ça tient très très facilement dans
la main ça c'est vraiment vraiment
vraiment cool et je vous dis par rapport
à d'autres smartphones du marché alors
là j'ai un iphone 6 s vous le comparez à
côté c'est juste minuscule carrément je
prends le wimax 3 qui est juste
énormissime en garde et non regardez le
truc
regardez le truc le plus petit
smartphone 4g qui existe à côté d'un
truc de ouf
celui-là il fait quasiment 7 pouces là
il fait devient vieux 45 pouces c'est
hallucinant en dimension plus il est
vraiment minuscule île fait 92,3 mm par
43 mm par 13 mm d'épaisseur et il pèse
62 g
hallucinant 62 g après ce qui est cool
c'est comme ce smartphone vous n'allez
pas globalement faire grand chose
n'allait pas passer des heures dessus à
jouer à des jeux passer des heures à
faire des réseaux sociaux et compagnie
du coup l'autonomie et va être assez
énorme parce qu'il faut savoir vous avez
une batterie de 950 millions terreur à
l'intérieur donc toute petite batterie
mais une fois de plus l'écran consomme
que dalle vous n'allez pas à passer à
des heures dessus avoue défoncer les
yeux donc au final vous allez le garder
une journée très très facilement voire
plus si affinités entre points de
détails vous avez du bleu
tous quatre points à l'intérieur joue
les dix double carte sim extension de
mémoire donc associe plutôt cool en
termes de puissance de v une puce quatre
coeurs qui va jusqu'à 1,1 giga hertz
bon je voulais ni appareil photo de 2
mégapixels 8 mégapixels à l'arrière avec
auto focus list qui fonctionne pas trop
lui en demander
mais qui fonctionne et vous pouvez faire
de la vidéo jusqu'en 1080p et il est
dispo en blanc en noir et en blanc je
vous ai dit une fois de plus si vous
intéresse vous ai mis un lien en bas
dans la description
voilà un peu pour ce test aujourd'hui du
smartphone 4g le plus petit au monde
le jelly pro c'est hallucinant majesco
j'en reviens pas de trop dites moi c'est
un smartphone comme sa minuscule un sens
pour vous peut vous intéresser
surtout que vous avez vraiment de
labrecque hadji à l'intérieur il marche
très très bien pour téléphoner tout ce
que vous voulez il est top dites moi ce
que vous en pensez vous marquez tout ça
en commentaire vous invite bien
évidemment à rester connectés pense
qu'il va y avoir plein de tests de trucs
un peu plus grand que ça rassurez-vous
choix clair ne fait le mini modèles vous
marquez tout ça on reste connectés ya
des surprises qui vont arriver d'ici
quelques jours des ordis qui vont être
testé plusieurs dit or dit d'elle va y
avoir un ordi de asus va y avoir aussi
un nouveau macbook pro qu'on va tester
des nouveautés qui vont arriver donc je
vous invite une fois de plus à faire une
seule chose à deux choses en réalité la
première vous vous abonnez vous cliquez
sur le bouton rouge et vous activer la
cloche et le deuxième point vous restez
connectés ont ce suivi on parle voilà
tout ça tout ça je vous embrasse merci
d'être là plus en plus nombreux toujours
plus nombreux prenez soin de vous et à
très bientôt
[Musique]